One thing I'd like to look at is the
average number of minutes students spend
in the classroom during
their first week.
Right now I have a bunch of engagement
records for different students, and
they're not in any particular order.
First, I'd like to separate out
the engagement records into groups where
each group contains all the engagement
records for a particular student.
I'll represent these groups using
a dictionary where the keys are student
account keys and the values are lists
of engagement records for that student.
Next, I'll compute the total number of
minutes spent in the classroom by each
student by summing up the number of
minutes in each engagement record for
that student.
Finally, I'll compute
the average of the totals
to get the answer I'm looking for.
Now I'll show you the code I
used to solve this problem.
First I created the dictionary I
mentioned to group engagement data by
the account key.
You can see that I used the defaultdict
instead of a vanilla dictionary.
If you haven't seen Python's
defaultdict before, that's okay.
It allows you to specify
a default value.
In this case I've specified list.
That means if I ever try to look
up a key in the dictionary and
that key is not there,
I'll get the empty list instead.
You'll see how this can
be helpful in a minute.
Then I looped through each
engagement record and
saved the account key in this variable.
Next I looked up the list of engagement
records for that account key.
Here's where the defaultdict that
comes in handy if I had never
added that account key yet,
then I get the empty list.
Then I append this engagement record
to the list of engagement records for
that account key.
Next I wanted to add up the number of
minutes visited by each account and
I decided to save that
in this dictionary.
So this dictionary
will store a number for
each account key,
instead of a list of engagement records.
Next I looped over the dictionary
I created previously.
And by looping over the .items,
I got both the key and
the value for
each entry in the dictionary.
For each account,
the number of minutes starts at 0.
Next I loop over each engagement record
in the list of engagement records for
that student.
And I add the number of minutes that
student visited in that engagement
record to the total number
of minutes for the student.
Finally, I store that number
of minutes under that account
key in the new dictionary.
Now I'm ready to take the average
of those totals, and for
that the account keys
are no longer relevant.
I'm just interested in
the numbers themselves.
So I'll use the .values method to
get out just the values from that
dictionary.
Now I could calculate the mean by hand,
but
instead I'm going to use
a library called numpy to do it.
You'll be seeing a lot of
numpy later in this course.
And I've imported it using
the line import numpy as np.
Adding as np allows me to later
refer to the numpy library as np,
instead of referring to it as numpy.
It's just a little shorter and
easier to type.
You don't have to do this, but
lots of code posted online will have
this convention, so
it's good to have seen it before.
Then I can take the mean
by calling np.mean and
passing in the total minutes.
I see that the average number
of minutes spent was 647.
I'm interesting in knowing more
than just the mean here, though.
I'd also like to know what's
the standard deviation and
what's the minimum and
what's the maximum.
It turns out numpy has functions
to calculate those as well.
They are np.std, np.min and np.max.
Now, you might know that Python
actually also has a min and
max function that you can use
without importing the numpy library.
You'll learn later why you might
want to use numpy's version instead.
But for
now I'm just going to go ahead and
use it since I've already
imported the library.
And when I run this I see that
the standard deviation is pretty large,
larger than the mean.
The minimum is 0 and
the maximum is about 10,000 minutes.
That's a huge maximum and
in fact there's gotta be a problem here,
because when you calculate it out,
that's actually slightly more than
the total number of minutes in one week.
So something has gone wrong.